our next guest wants to be wants you to
be able to sweat your face off
while looking fantastic she is a former
u.s women's national soccer player who
co-founded a line of high performance
makeup
and sun care called sweat cosmetics
please give a warm welcome to leslie
osborne hello leslie
hi leslie oh cheers to you
i am like i wish i could mainline this
caffeine this morning
i'm serious right i am like okay
fantastic um so leslie i was doing my
research on you
and i just want you to know really
quickly that you had a quote that said
uh
girls in sports um hold on i haven't
highlighted right here you'd think i'd
have it pulled up
but you talked about the importance of
girls in sports and how vital it is
and i always heard that growing up girls
in sports is the most crucial thing you
can do
for girls so i read that
doing my research i put the packet down
i picked up the phone
and i called olives i want her to do
sports and right now
it's obviously so challenging so i
started searching for maybe people who
could
do one-on-one with her or at least be
waiting down the line when it is safe
and she tends to do summer camps but i
just think
you're so right about that there's so
much data and research
about how important sports is for men
women children and the fact that you and
your
teammates found a cosmetics
company and founded this company sweat
cosmetics that
enables women to look their best and
feel the best
while they're working out this was not
in the marketplace
you are such an innovator
thanks drew you should be our newest
ambassador seriously
i would like to be because i've taken a
lot of workout classes throughout my
life and i've noticed women wearing
makeup and i've seen the need i even
tried to do flower fit
at one point because i do see the
desire to keep your makeup intact while
working out some women feel more
empowered that way
so what was it what was the catalyst
especially with the sun protection
yeah i mean we always felt if you if we
felt good we would play better
and when we were playing professional
soccer and this is dating back to
2004-2005 when i was on the us team
i remember like sneaking in my cubby and
putting on lip gloss and i remember abby
wambach
like rolling her eyes at me like oh my
god but
for some reason when i felt good and
look good i played better
so um fast forward in 2012 i have four
awesome partners we were playing
professional soccer
we were still having that same problem
why were there not problems or
products out there designed for active
women that could give you sun protection
but
also could get you through a workout and
there were none so it took us three
years to actually
you know find a chemist to research to
raise money to come out with our
products but we wanted a sunscreen
makeup that were designed for active
women and
not even women going to work out women
that are just on the go and let's be
serious
nowadays that's all we do we're
multitasking so
if we felt like the products were clean
and natural and easy to use and could
make us look
somewhat put together why wouldn't we go
out and create that and we did in 2015
and we're still going strong five years
later
well you've started a revolution you
know you really have and i think it's a
real
call to real needs out there in the
world not only for sun protection which
is vital but also just
female empowerment or men i love your
packaging and componentry and the
functionality of it too
in fact can we check in with victoria
real quick and see how she's
rocking it still going victoria
making me feel like i am a lazy lazy
little couch potato
and i usually wake up at like four in
the morning to work out before work and
what did i do this morning i slept
until the last second so thank you
victoria for showing us how it's done
how are you feeling
i'm feeling great i'm really feeling
confident with this makeup so this line
is awesome
i really like it well thank you victoria
and thank you leslie for everything that
you've contributed both in sports and
your fox
you know newscasting and now with sweat
cosmetics you
are a mom and a wife and i love your
instagram and your whole life story and
it's been a pleasure
to you know shine a light on your ever
so important
innovative and awesome business
seriously you saw a white space
in the industry and that is not easy to
do so congratulations sweat cosmetic
ladies and gentlemen
check it out it's on our website thank
you victoria and thank you leslie so
much
thank you drew thank you now go get your
sweat on